la tendance est au réchauffement enfin
sachez que l'histoire retiendra que le
15 novembre fut un jour béni des dieux
car concomitamment le froid a fait sa
grande dévalé sur notre pays
le beaujolais nouveau est arrivé avec
les conséquences éthylique que vous
connaissez et la france s'est enrichi
d'une nouvelle citoyenne une semaine
supplémentaire en la personne de laura
smet alias laura hallyday fille de
l'idole des jeunes et de nathalie baye
sur cet événement considérable qui
décoiffe
les réactions à chaud du papa après
l'épreuve dans la dernière ligne droite
l'a senti clinique casaque rouge stock
belge
j'ai pas de déclaration à faire ceci
bien petite fille qui fait 3 kg 950 g
elle s'appellera voir comment va la
maman si la maman mabiala peu fatigué
dans ce cas normal elle se repose un peu
là et il va bien jusqu'à demain 80 bd va
bien on doit aussi voulu une fille vous
êtes content je suis ravie je suis rêve
je ne ferais pas mieux